company I'm a professor and vice chair
in the department
um Bill our chair is away so it's my
pleasure to introduce uh Christina
Turner today
um this is uh her Symposium and this is
a reminder or for those who are not in
the department who are um watching this
either live or later when it's recorded
and posted
um the Symposium is part of the process
um for our dissertation students in
which they're really thinking about the
background you know kind of the prior
art where the real you know kind of open
questions that they can address
um and so this is that synthesis of the
literature review and thinking that
they've been doing in terms of the ideas
that will uh really be the kind of uh
formation for their proposal so they do
the Symposium then they'll actually
develop a proposal with uh their attack
and then uh they'll actually have a
proposal defense that will
um again be live so uh let me just tell
you a little bit about our speaker today
so uh Christina is one of our nlm uh
pre-doctoral fellows uh she did her
Bachelor's of science at Occidental
College in 2014
um and also did her Masters at Western
Washington University uh her background
is in molecular biology and microbial
ecology
um and she mentioned and she actually
wrote her own introduction which I'm
paraphrasing but that she loves to think
about microbes in their interaction with
the environments and I think you'll see
a lot of that today and she's also
fascinated about thinking about the
human body as a complex ecosystem and
you will definitely see some of that
thinking uh today
um and she really would like to
understand the environmental impact of
microbial interactions in host Health
doing health health as a holistic
approach to improve someone's physical
um and mental well-being she is from
Portland uh and she looks forward to
seeing where this project takes her and
with that I will stop talking and hand
it over to Christina all right thanks
Shannon uh yeah I'm excited to share
some ideas I have and what I've learned
so far about the gut microbiome
resilience as a metric to predict
overall human health and I mean Shannon
kind of already got to this point but
this uh topic or idea is pretty much
based on my interest in applying our
understanding of the gut microbiome to
better understand our overall health and
well-being
I'm going to start oops oh how do you
change okay there we go I'm going to
start by sharing our the overarching
question that kind of motivates this and
then some background information on
salutogenesis gut microbiome and disease
and applying this concept of ecological
resilience I'll share our problem space
or what we know and what needs to be
done some prior R and current approaches
and then I'll share what current gaps
are still there in potential
opportunities
so the overarching question that
motivates this topic area is kind of
represented by this diagram I made of
twin a and twin B representing two
individuals who have the same sex very
similar genetics diet lifestyle what
they do any medication or comorbidities
they have let's say all the variables
are very
very similar to the same and they're
exposed to the same disturbance or
challenge so some examples would be like
a loss of a loved one a car crash a
heart attack or stroke of cancer
what's interesting though is that even
though all the variables are the same or
similar twin a might come out of this
disturbance with very poor health or no
recovery versus torn B has a quick
recovery back to the original healthy
state
or maybe the disturbance doesn't affect
that person's health at all so then the
question comes up
why can two very similar individuals
who are exposed to the same disturbance
respond so differently
and rather than trying to identify all
the factors involved and characterizing
all the variables could we predict this
overall health response by defining and
developing a metric
to best answer this or tackle this
question we propose to take a
salutogenic approach and this
salatogenic model of Health
um
realize on this concept of understanding
and viewing Health as a process along a
Continuum between uh health and total
ill health so ease and disease right and
this is different from this traditional
pathogenesis approach that kind of looks
at origin of disease or how diseases are
developed so it's a more holistic
approach to understanding health
and salutogenesis really views the human
body as a system that contains
subsystems
a subsystem
of the human body is the gut microbiome
and it's well known that the health of
the gut microbiome is really important
in maintaining the health of the host
which is us
so a gut microbiome or more firmly the
gastrointestinal tract microbiome I
probably will be referring to this as
gut microbiome or GM just as a note
the microbiome is a collection of
microorganisms that include fungi
archaeoviruses and bacteria and these
microbes are closely evolved with the
host which is us and they have intricate
interactions to maintain this healthy
ecosystem and as a note the microbiome
is composed of all the microbes but I'm
going to be mainly focusing on bacteria
because that's where a lot of the
research is
so this left diagram you can see the
healthy gut ecosystem with different
types of bacteria so it's very diverse
there's a lot of different shapes and
colors of bacteria
and in this healthy gut
um the gut barrier is maintained so you
can see the intestinal epithelial cells
are a very tight-knit and they don't
allow anything in the luminal space of
the intestine to come through into the
bloodstream so this is the gut barrier
and a healthy gut ecosystems helps
maintain this
when there's a disturbance or challenge
whether it be internal or external this
uh community of microbes can get
disrupted and the balance of what
microbial are not what abundance can be
disrupted and when that happens it can
go into this dysbiotic state
commonly this this biotic state is
characterized by an overgrowth of one or
two types of bacteria
um and when this happens this ecosystem
the normal processes
um are dysregulated and this gut barrier
can be impaired and when this happens
um
microbes and microbial products can get
past this barrier and then into our
bloodstream causing endotoxemia and
endotoxemia often leads to inflammation
um
so in this situation this is usually
referred to as a gut microbiome and
dysbiosis and it's associated with many
diseases including inflammatory bowel
disease colorectal cancer obesity and
type 2 diabetes as well as uh
liver disease isn't also Alzheimer's
disease
so it's well known that gut microbiome
health is really important supporting
our health human health
and given that the gut microbiome is a
subsystem
of the the host the human it's crucial
to understand how the gut microbiome
Health Works one of the proposed metrics
to understand gut microbiome health is
this concept of resilience
uh and so I'm gonna cut whoops sorry
okay there we go so I'm going to kind of
talk about what resilience is
um
and I'm using the definition of
ecological resilience
and generally it's defined as the
ability of a system to resist or recover
from a challenge
and it is important to note that there
are many different definitions of
resilience
but I'm going to just go with this
General
one and if you look at this panel down
here this represents a stability
landscape also can be called a ball and
Basin diagram
the ball represents the system so let's
say it's the gut microbiome for this
instance and these basins or divots
represent a state
and
um if a disturbance
occurs on this system so here this shows
this external challenge occurring to
this individual which then affects the
gut microbiome and this gut microbiome
is at this Tipping Point or tipping a
critical threshold between states so
from here if the system is resilient
enough it can resist that disturbance
and return back to its original healthy
State versus if it's not resilient
enough or if the perturbation or
disturbance Is frequent and strong
enough the system can be pushed into
this alternate stable state
the clinical implication with this is
that this alternate stable State can be
resilient and it can confer a negative
phenotype to the host which
um this process occurring with the
resilient stable state with the negative
post phenotype has been proposed to be
linked with chronic diseases so diseases
that
treatments don't work or have a hard
time reverting to that healthy state
so there are some uh characteristics of
microbial communities that have been
found to kind of underlie resilience of
the gut microbiome
and these are kind of key
characteristics so I'm going to quickly
explain them
microbial diversity and functional
redundancy
are kind of key
so diversity simply put it's just the
number of different kinds of
microorganisms or
um and then the functional redundancy is
this phenomenon that microbes do where
you can have phylogenetically distinct
taxa that can place similar functional
roles
so this diagram on the left hand side
shows the distribution of the types of
bacteria this panel shows for oral
microbiome so your microbes in your
mouth
and it shows that firm acutes the green
one is the predominant bacteria compared
to the gut which looks very different
it's predominantly bacteroides what's
interesting though when you look at the
functions of the microbes so what
they're doing not just who who's there
the distribution of the functions based
on the colors it looks very similar
so this diagram is trying to show the
idea that even if you have different
taxa in your communities different types
of bacteria you can still have similar
functions and functional redundancy and
the diversity is important for
resilience and in gut microbiome for
keeping resilience because as an example
if you lose
one type of bacteria that Comforts a
important function
if you have a functionally redundant
taxa they can kind of replace that loss
function and keep the microbiome doing
its normal healthy um functions
so methods that are used to characterize
the microbiome
are 16s RNA Target Gene sequencing a
shotgun metagenomic sequencing and I
want to briefly go over these because
the approaches I'm going to share mostly
use use these and there are
different levels of methods used for
microbiome so I'm focusing on methods
that use DNA as an input but just so
everybody's aware there are methods that
use RNA and protein and metabolites but
a lot of the approaches are not there
yet so
you get DNA from host samples like skin
feces or saliva you could do this more
targeted approach that characterizes
just bacteria and you can look at the
phylogenetic diversity so different
types of bacteria and also the abundance
of Texa or types of bacteria and then
the shock and metagenomic approach
captures all the genes including host
genes and with that you could get
microbial Gene counts and then also uh
kind of
predict what kind of functions are
occurring
from this data you could do analyzes
such as Alpha and beta diversity
analyzes to compare differences in tax
cell within samples and then across
samples you can also do statistical and
machine learning approaches to predict
the distribution of data
you could also do co-occurrence Network
analyzes to understand what microbes are
present and how they're interacting a
lot of times you do this for a pre and
post disturbance to see how the
interactions change you could do
something similar but with metabolism to
see how the microbial functions change
and interact with each other
so that's kind of the background and I'm
going to get into the promo space so
what we're dealing with what do we know
and what do we still need
so we know so far that the gut
microbiome plays a significant role in
our health
it's agreed that defining what a healthy
goat microbiome is nearly impossible and
this is because of the inter individual
variance in our in our microbiomes
across individuals uh the gut microbiome
is also a very Dynamic and Complex
Community so characterizing the changes
and defining one healthy definition is
tricky
um
the importance of this idea of
resilience to maintain a healthy gut has
been found and is agreed upon that
resilience is key
um
and then defining what a huge healthy
human is is also kind of challenging
it's been proposed that using this gut
microbiome resilience as a surrogate for
human health
and this is
um just to know this is just a proposal
um there's no data or any validated
models to support this yet it's also
been theorized that this gut microbiome
resilience and human health have a
relationship but there's few data to
support this still
so our overarching need is we need a
metric for overall human health and gut
microbiome resilience has been
hypothesized to be a promising candidate
to further kind of assess that question
we need a robust assessment
of gut microbiome resilience metrics and
then ultimately we would need to
validate a model to quantify this
resilience and then apply it as a
potential indicator of overall host
health
so I'm gonna share current approaches
that apply this ecological resilience to
understand system health and because
resilience has been applied to a wide
range of systems and in very different
ways I organize them into three
categories so one of them
they apply resilience to measure or they
apply metrics and ecological models to
measure that resilience in systems like
coral reef or soil systems or rivers and
then they also apply the idea of
resilience to measure human health
and then the last category they apply
resilience to measure the health of the
microbiome so I'm going to kind of go
through each category and talk about the
approaches
Okay so
the first few approaches in this
environmental systems area
um
chafara all proposed using this concept
or phenomena called critical slowing
down to measure Dynamic indicators of
resilience
in this phenomena which I find really
interesting called critical slowing down
it's an early warning indicator of a
Tipping Point
um so if we just use this as a reference
here's a an attraction of basin and a
system
and the idea is that when the system
gets closer to this Tipping Point
the recovery rate slows down so to
estimate
um if a system is going to be pushed
into another state you can measure this
critical slogan down to predict that
shift
so this approach applies that critical
slowing down and
the key assumption with this approach is
that
the they assume that the system is
exposed to many small perturbations
rather than like one acute disturbance
the advantage of using these
um time series data that kind of
captures these small perturbations and
you can estimate resilience based on
those to calculate the pattern of micro
recoveries
um so micro recovery would be how a
system kind of recovers back to that
original healthy equilibria
and then based on this framework of
political slowing down they were able to
identify measures that characterize it
and they turned them these Dynamic
indicators of resilience or di orbs one
of them is variants
um
one is variance which can be seen here
with temporal autocorrelation
so if you look this left panel
represents a system with high resilience
and then this right one represents a
system with low resilience and the idea
here is that a system in with low
resilience has a slow recovery back to
that initial State shown here
and then you can estimate these
fluctuations that occur along time
series and based on those fluctuations
you estimate these measures
in a state that has low resilience you
have higher temporal autocorrelation in
variance seen with these crazy Dragon
lines
um and this represents the correlation
between the states and the changes in
the states
uh the next characteristic that
indicates resilience is
cross-correlation so that's correlation
and the changes between different
elements of the system
uh and high cross correlation indicates
a lower resiliency so that's
represented here
and this approach is
still a proposal it actually hasn't they
didn't test it on any model so that's
probably important to note
um
and they also propose that you can
estimate these do IRS from vital
parameters so some of the examples they
give is like blood pressure
to predict somebody's Frailty uh another
parameter they propose is a mood for
things like risks of depression and then
specific for the microbiome another
parameter they propose is like the
intake the amount of uh
fiber intake because fiber is associated
with a stable and healthy gut microbiome
another approach applies the concept of
entropy and data complexity to assess
resilience of assess of a system they
measure the change in this entropy
measure they they use called singular
value or decomposition
and they calculate this from a
multivariate biological metric
and this workflow kind of shows you
start with this multivariate data set
you use this SVD method to calculate
entropy which is then associated with
complexity of your system and their
approach then takes
uh this measure of entropy and exposes
the system to a disturbance and compares
the change in complexity and entropy and
if you have a higher complexity change
then they estimate that that system is
resilient so this is based on the
assumption that the complexity in your
data is correlated or proportional to
the complexity in your system
and so they use this complexity chain to
then
predict if your system is high or low
resilience they tested their model
on a phytoplankton community in the
biological variables they inputted to
the model include diversity species
abundance cell density biomass
chlorophyll a concentration and then a
function that's specific to
phytoplankton
two more approaches in this
environmental systems category mean exit
time or life expectancy was applied as a
measure of resilience
and this approach was similar to the
first one that looked at small
perturbations over a Time series and
they calculate mean exit time which is
the time it takes for assistant to leave
that stability Basin so also a similar
idea of predicting the shift
and it's estimated from the fluctuations
in the system
they applied the stability landscape
framework and the long driven approach
which is to calculate the fluctuations
to then be able to calculate this mean
exit time
um
they tested their model on cyanobacteria
biomass over a Time series in a
freshwater lake and this shows the
abundance across the time
and then they calculated these two key
components of the launch of an equation
called Drift and diffusion and then
using that they calculated the mean exit
time which is shown with these uh green
lines and the idea here is that a
shorter mean exit time
suggest that the system shifts between
states more frequently implying that the
system is less resilient
the next approach uses artificial neural
network or a machine learning technique
to predict water quality resilience and
they use this method to rank water
basins based on their level of
resilience and the goal here is to be
able to identify which water basins need
uh
what prompt restoration strategies
one of the limitations here is that
the input they use for their model is
this predefined validated index for
water quality and so if we were to apply
something like this to the microbiome we
would need to uh
select and Define what kind of input we
would use
So based on these approaches from using
ecological models this kind of makes me
honestly can we adapt these methods or
models to provide novel metrics for the
microbiome how can we adapt It Is it
feasible does it make sense
so in the next category of approaches is
in the area of human health
and these approaches look at the
condition of the the host or human and
then infer microbiome health so they
don't necessarily measure microbiome
directly
but the association is there
so this first approach identified a core
microbiota and based on the presence of
that core microbiota or not they
inferred the resilience of children they
did a longitudinal study that
characterized fecal microbiota of
children in one day care across four
variables including travel antibiotic
use diarrheal events and then age and
their goal was to identify which
specific bacterial types might confer
this increased resistance and resilience
towards developing diarrhea
they Define a core microbiota as
bacterial species that are present in
all samples for each individual child
um
and then this oops
sorry
okay there we go so this diagram
represents just one of the analyzes they
did looking at a Time series
of bacteria composition from one child
you had diarrhea 60 days
before and so they
look at the change in observed species
richness so the number of speech species
and you can see that increases over the
60 days after the diarrhea so it shows
some recovery
and then they also look at the diversity
in the community and that also recovers
but as a comparison
when they did this with a child who
didn't have diarrhea they
um their species richness and diversity
recovered after closer to 45 days 40 to
45 days versus this child took 60 days
so then they infer that um
they infer the resilience based on this
presence or absence of the core
microbiota
this other approach
assess the resilience of the host based
on
the microbial composition changes after
a stress exposure and a rat model of
PTSD
so if you kind of follow this diagram
with me
um
they
had a SPF is the stress exposure they
tested so they collected fecal sample
fecal samples and urine before the
exposure and then they had their SPF
stress group and then their control
group
they like let them rest for a little and
then they did a behavioral and anxiety
tests
uh and the output of the behavioral test
was an anxiety measure
that's already been like validated in
Psychiatry based on the level of this
anxiety measure they divided the stress
exposed rats into resilient or
susceptible groups and then they looked
at what bacteria are in the resilient
versus susceptible rats they did find a
difference
um but again they don't really measure
resilience they just infer uh what a
microbiome associated with the resilient
host looks like
and the last area these approaches are
specific to
um measuring or estimating resilience of
the microbiome
so this one from Shaw at all applied a
stability landscape framework to predict
post-perturbation States and to infer
resilience
and they use this approach to model the
recovery of the gut microbiome after an
antibiotic treatment
um
so they only assume that the system can
be in
two states so one is a a healthy state
or one is a diseased dysbiotic state
and then as one of the parameters they
use phylogenic diversity so how many
types of bacteria in the community and
you can see that here
um
a
so this y-axis represents diversity so a
system with high diversity is resilient
a system with lower diversity is in this
alternate State and represents has
um
lower resilience
uh and then their model because they're
only assuming two states uh they Model A
perturbation as an Impulse so opposite
from the small natural perturbations but
an acute impulse
and then the idea is that this system
can go into
um
this one state which would be one model
or it could get transitioned into this
other state so the goal of this approach
was to really simplify uh the complexity
in this ecosystem
and this next approach uses functional
redundancy as a resilience indicator of
the human gut microbiota and this
approach created a network that links
microbes to the genes and their genomes
called genomic content Network and this
was to investigate the origin of
functional redundancy they applied their
Network and analyzed publicly available
data sets of SQL microbiome transplant
and fmt
could be seen as an acute disturbance so
it's when you take a healthy person's
feces and
apply it to somebody who needs a
um
reorganize gut microbiome if they have
like diarrhea or something so it's a
it's a treatment method
so as to kind of explain what they did
um
this top panel shows a taxonomic profile
so what bacteria are in the samples and
then they
created their genomic content Networks
and this is just hypothetical to show
their the conceptual model
um
so you link the taxa to a gene and this
left one
this left one represents
each taxa has a unique genome so the
functional redundancy in this community
is very low this one represents some
taxa have unique genes but then there
are others that share the same genes so
for instance this purple taxa shares the
same gene with this red taxa and then
this very right graph represents a
highly functionally redundant Community
because all these taxes share similar
genes from the similar genomes
and then they calculate functional
profiles of each sample based on
functional diversity
which is how many functions are within a
sample
and combine that with functional
redundancy to calculate that profile
and so this left plot kind of represents
a community that has a high functional
diversity but low functional redundancy
and then this middle one it's comparable
and then this right one shows that
although they have a low functional
functional diversity so there's not that
many functions occurring in this
microbial Community but because the
genes are redundant they have high
functional redundancy so then they would
term this as a resilient microbiome and
based when they did the analysis with
the fecal micro fecal microbiome
transplant data set they found that
resilient recipients of the treatment
who have a high uh resilience or high
functional redundancy the treatment did
not work as well because their
microbiome was so stable the donor
microbiome didn't um
stick
and then the last approach they predict
the metabolic potential and use that as
a resilience measure for gut meta
genomes so they use shotgun metagenomics
and they estimated resilience through
bacterial richness diverge diversity and
evenness specific to this microbial
byproduct called short chain fatty acids
or scfas and it's well known that these
microbial
molecules or products help regulate our
our gut and maintain health
and the three main ones are propionate
butary and acetate so they use these to
infer resilience
and for resilience and they used they
tested their
um approach on shotgun metagenomic data
sets of 12 populations and they compared
individuals from an industrial setting
to non-industrial
and they compare these two populations
because it's known that individuals who
are in industrial settings have a lower
abundance so let's see it as cfas
and then based on the gene counts uh
they predicted functional profiles
so one of the questions I got from this
approach is could we use scfa counts or
abundance as a potential metric for
resilience for a microbial community
so then that brings us into what gaps
are still present
the effect of the daily natural
disturbances versus acute kind of
impulse perturbations the difference in
those effects are still not very known
on how they affect government for biome
resilience disability the methods for
quantifying gut microbiome resilience
has not been established and the model
or guidelines for assessing resiliency
and how to best correlate them with
clinical outcomes is missing and then
best practices for
quantifying resilience
of the human gut has not been provided
yet
some of the opportunities that are
available in this area
um
assessing the feasibility of applying
these different ecological methods and
models to measure gut microbiome
resilience is still needed and could be
did
so for instance
um assessing how to apply artificial
neural network to microbiometrics or the
mean exit time to best measure
resilience of the gut microbiome
assessing that kind of models would be
an opportunity
comparing those methods and evaluing
metrics in relation to host health and
then further defining assumptions and
then also identifying what kind of data
would be required and challenges and
limitations for applying those methods
and metrics
the next level of opportunities that are
available would be to develop a
framework that's reproducible
for measuring gut microbiome resilience
and then in this area we would need to
evaluate the definitions and metrics and
characteristics as well
kind of uh down the line or ultimately
one of the opportunities would be to
integrate gut microbiome resilience data
with host clinical outcomes
to develop the most biologically
accurate measure of overall post Health
we would need to consider what kind of
data we need to look at and
looking at time series data and doing
longitudinal analysis to compare the
changes across time to see to be able to
capture the fluctuations would be
crucial
considering what kind of disturbance
imodo is also crucial so do model
impulse disturbances or the more small
and natural daily perturbations
defining what a baseline state looks
like and what a resilient response looks
like is crucial too and then
what kind of
host response would be defined as
healthy and that one would probably be
challenging but that's key
and the last consideration
with applying resilience to gut
microbiome as a metric is that
resilience is very context dependent
um
so
it's very context dependent So based on
the system the characteristics of
resilience and the metrics and indices
that are applied would differ
in conclusion
assessing the feasibility of gut
microbiome resilience as a measure of a
host of host Health would require kind
of looking at surrogate measures
definitions metrics and considering what
kind of data types are needed and the
availability of data
um
a metric for overall health
especially using gut microbiome as a
proxy applied in research and
translation would help us understand the
relationship between
um Health our health human health and
gut micro bound stability it also help
us kind of better understand what the
drivers and mechanisms chronic
inflammation we could also improve
treatments and diagnoses and prognoses
predict disease severity or or risk
better and also with a metric like that
we could monitor Lifestyle Changes
disease progression or treatment
hey and thank you for listening I'd like
to thank my advisor Shannon and all the
demise faculty and administration also
uh my dear my students and fellows
thanks to the grant
great that's fantastic so we're now
going to have time for
uh questions and there's one that goes
back to
um the twin I guess they're asking for a
clarification Christina which is asking
if the twins are identical
yeah I'd say so
yeah I was I was assuming they're
identical just as an example to show you
know two individuals that can be as
similar as possible
right because then you'd really be
focusing you'd be able to
um remove the genetic component and just
think about environmental right yeah
okay other questions for Christina
and you can obviously turn on your um
unmute and ask a question directly or
you can put it in the chat either one
hi Christina this is Mike Winnie great
talk
I was wondering
um you talked a little bit about
longitudinal analysis I just want the
data on the time scale at which you know
if you had a magic pill to correct your
microbiome how how quickly does that
translate in or into changing Health
state
yeah that's a very good question there's
one study
right
I can't find it find it but there is one
study that
um suggested 12 timepoons
is kind of the key to uh accurately
capturing like changes in the
fluctuations in the system but
um
I didn't really see any study that
assessed that for microbiome changes
specifically a lot of the studies
let me go back to it so
for instance like
this study that looked at antibiotic
treatment they used a data set that was
like a year long
and then
uh this one that looked like at the
diarrhea and the children they also
looked at a data set that was a year
long
so
yeah yeah thanks
any other questions for Christina any
ideas remember this is her symposium
so you have the building I just ask
questions about the talk but just to
kind of think about what she's laid out
in terms of her ideas and obviously
um you can always email her directly if
you'd prefer not to um do it this way
but we just love to get your input for
her this is true for all of our students
with their Symposium
um any ideas you have or if this
resonates at all
hey Christina this is Sean Gibbons here
um great talk
I had a kind of Devil's Advocate
question for you so resilience is is one
way to measure sort of maybe like a
health State for the microbomb but you
could imagine
disease states are resilient as well
right
um I could maybe argue that recurrent C
diff is a resilient State have you
thought about that
could you explain the second part about
disease State resilience
that potentially dysbiotic or
unsub-optimal ecological compositions of
the microbiota can themselves be quite
resilient you have makers of resilience
and so resilience is sort of almost an
agnostic you know uh not has no good or
bad flavor to it in that case it could
be either or either or depending on
context right
yeah I think that's a really good point
um
I'm kind of holding myself back from
getting too far into this because it
gets into proposal stuff but
um my thinking is
uh it's kind of crucial to include host
health information to associate with the
state conditions so the resilience
so then based on what the health outcome
is whether it be chronic inflammation or
dysbiotic we can associate that with the
resilience
[Music]
um
yeah but that is a good question I
haven't really thought about it too much
um
so I think
having that component of
the condition of the state would be key
and then we could work on how to best
kind of Define that and a measure that
would capture it
that makes sense but that's a very good
question
great thanks thank you thanks so much
just as a note about that before we go
to the question just kind of adding on
to what Sean said this would be really
relevant in cancer
right where we think about the evolution
and kind of ecological aspects when we
think about the tumor
um especially thinking about resistance
Etc so resiliency of the cancer as well
right would be a different
interpretation
um okay so your next question is from
Chris he said
um what would a long-term vision of the
clinical application of a better
understanding of the gut micro
microbiome look like would this be more
proactive Health recommendations or
monitoring acute treatments or both
so if I'm understanding your question
right Chris
um there are many
proposed like applications of something
like this so one of um you know you
mentioned like proactive Health
recommendations using a metric like this
to kind of monitor
um how somebody's Lifestyle Changes
improves their health so kind of more
for monitoring Improvement which could
also be applied to treatments and to
monitor how well a treatment is working
or how it's not
um
so it could be applied in that area too
I think he's I think the question is for
you right it's kind of what you I mean
if anyone could answer but but you know
if we talk about a long-term Vision
right so we think about the significance
of this work if it was successful
what is the future of clinical
applications in your opinion right if
you had a yeah you could say if you had
a crystal ball but you could also just
base it on what you're thinking so is it
is this idea of more proactive is it the
monitoring an actual you know
therapeutic aspect or both or
um something different
I guess I was thinking both but
um
I guess I was leaning more towards
um using it as kind of a predictive
measure
uh to predict for instance
um
in clinical depression
this concept of resilience has been
applied and it's found that
individuals with depression kind of show
this
critical threshold or Tipping Point into
a state that's associated with clinical
depression and symptoms so if we could
use this metric to kind of predict if
somebody's getting closer to that
Tipping Point so then we can apply
I don't know whether it be medication or
well
suggest more exercise or a healthier
diet to help that person stay in the
stable state so it would be a measure to
predict somebody's Health to avoid a
shift into that unhealthy state
that's kind of the
main application that I'm interested in
Chris do you want to add anything to
that or is that does that answer your
question
um yeah that does answer my question
um I guess you know the first thing that
comes to mind for me is things like uh
dietary recommendations because that's
you know pretty low cost and and
practical
um but you know the the monitoring
stuff's interesting it just seems to me
that for
um
you know to like predict a change in
someone's treatment uh I'm just curious
of like how practical that is to
implement because you know if you take
like with that is that like regular
fecal samples or something like that
like you know it's like patient
compliance it you know it seems like
that could potentially be a challenge if
it's more of a hassle I don't know I'm
just curious like what the
implementation would look like but it
seems like uh there are a lot of a lot
of possibilities
yeah there definitely is and I think one
of the
um
finding a measure using the gut
microbiome
to estimate that overall health is that
you can just look at the fecal
microbiome or a fecal sample and so
that's not very intrusive
um you know the number the frequency at
which you have to sample is unknown so
if it's like every day that wouldn't be
very practical
um but for instance if it was like every
three months maybe that's a little more
practical for a patient to go in or
provide a fecal sample and then you can
do simple 16s to look at the the
diversity of the bacteria to kind of
assess if they're improving or if
they're
um not progressing as much as they want
so yeah I was thinking about with people
symbols yeah that makes sense thanks
any other questions for
um Christina she did put her email in
the chat
um the people they want to follow up
with her but anyone else
okay well then uh we'll just join me in
congratulating her again on a successful
Symposium a great job Christina
um thank you all
thank you ready
okay
all right